si je recule un petit peu que si je
m'assois dans la maison mais pour tous
elle est c'est fini et puis de vue sur
le lac
catherine de montigny a perdu sa vue sur
le lac des deux montagnes
voici le coucher de soleil devant sa
maison avant la digue et après la digue
est ce que je vends et je m'en vais à
perte ou je reste ici devant mon mur de
métal
c'est le dilemme de plusieurs riverains
qui poursuivent la municipalité de
sainte marthe sur le lac pour qu'elle
abaisse de mettre la nouvelle digue
pourquoi de montagne à pointe-calumet
ira aux jeunes avec un match de moins
puis à cette marque sa professeure
pourtant on est sur le même lac et on
est tous des municipalités riveraines de
montagne et pointe-calumet ont conclu
qu'une digue de 25,7 m au dessus du
niveau de la mer est suffisante pour
contrer des crues centenaire sainte
marthe a évalué à 26,5 m nos ingénieurs
ont travaillé avec hydro québec
les ingénieurs de débats des grands
barrages alors nous notre auteur a été
décidé par la recommandation donc on a
eu des seins généreux qui t'aiment
dossier mais est ce que une déduction de
montagne qui pourraient absolument pas
absolument pas on ne s'est pas assis
autour d'une table parce que pointe
calumet ont commencé à ma mémoire est
bonne a commencé après nous et de
montagne avait commencé avant nous des
travaux urgents qu'il fallait entamer au
plus vite de montagne finaliser sa digue
en janvier une digue en gruyère assumer
en partie par les riverains et la
municipalité sainte-marthe-sur-le-lac
terminera dans les prochains jours
l'installation des palplanches sur tout
son territoire tandis qu à
pointe-calumet les structures ont été
installés entre la 13e et la 25e avenue
laissant une partie du territoire à
découvert avant le muret dont la hauteur
sera augmentée en 2021
on était inquiet c'est sûr mais on
travaille fort être prêt pour la
prochaine crue les équipes sont en place
déjà depuis quelques quelques mots les
élus assurent que tout est en place pour
protéger les citoyens ce printemps un
printemps sans lac à l'horizon ici marie
josée paquet comme radio-canada sainte
marthe sur le lac